donc hier à priori les français ont élu
le huitième président de la vème
république le peuple apparaît mais at-il
bien parlé alors bien sûr le peuple a
sans doute massivement voter utile
notamment au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle et n'a donc pas dit ce
qu'il pensait vraiment tout ça parce que
l'on lui dans une démocratie avec un
scrutin de coûts mais mettons-les
scrutin à part pour aujourd'hui imaginer
que on ait choisi le meilleur scrutant
qui existe et que le peuple a clairement
exprimé sa vraie préférence pour un tel
est ce que le peuple aura alors
forcément bien parler ou dit autrement
at-il vraiment voter pour le bien de la
france
après tout si chaque citoyen vote dans
son propre intérêt
les expressions des intérêts individuels
pourraient ne pas correspondre aux biens
du groupe
d'ailleurs des études empiriques
montrent qu'elle plupart des citoyens
reprochent aux autres citoyens l'égoïsme
de leur vote qui pourrait alors se faire
au détriment de l'intérêt national et
donc l'égoïsme des citoyens ne serait-il
pas un vrai problème pour la démocratie
l'une des découvertes les plus
stupéfiantes et des sciences politiques
et que la réponse à cette question est
très probablement non des études
empiriques des votes des américains
montrent que les électeurs sont presque
prêts à se tirer une balle dans le pied
pour le bien de la nation
les victimes de crimes et les résidents
de quartiers dangereux ne sont pas plus
en faveur de mesures contre la
criminalité
les personnes âgées sont moins en faveur
de la sécurité sociale que les jeunes
les hommes sont plus en faveur de
l'avortement que les femmes et beaucoup
parmi les plus riches aux démocrates
pour la redistribution des richesses
bonne nouvelle donc en tout cas selon
l'économiste brian k plane quand nos
concitoyens vont aux urnes ils ne
pensent pas à leur petite personne
il pense à la patrie à leurs concitoyens
voire à toute l'espèce humaine et
cherche avant tout à faire ce qui est
bien pour les leurs les citoyens ne
votent pas pour leurs intérêts
individuels ils votent pour un idéal de
société
je vous invite à méditer ça c'est un
communiste veut plus de redistribution
des richesses ce n'est en général pas
pour qu'ils puissent clan douillet dans
son coin et profiter du travail des
autres inverse si un capitaliste veut
moins de régulation des marchés ce n'est
en général pas pour qu'ils puissent
s'enrichir au profit du travail des
autres communistes et capitalistes
veulent en fait tous la même chose une
société où tout le monde se porte mieux
mais alors si chacun des citoyens votent
pour ce qu'ils pensent être l'intérêt
national nous suffirait d'être une vraie
démocratie pour résoudre tous les maux
de nos sociétés et non pas si vite
les citoyens veulent bien faire mais est
ce qu'ils font vraiment le nécessaire
pour être sûr de bien faire ça peut
paraître être une trivialité pour nombre
d'entre vous mais la quasi totalité des
électeurs sont très mal informés au
moment d'aller aux urnes
la quasi totalité n'ont lu aucun
programme des candidats à la
présidentielle
la quasi-totalité non virtuellement
aucune notion d'économie la quasi
totalité n'ont aucune idée du nombre
d'immigrants par an la quasi-totalité
non virtuellement aucune notion de
finance
la quasi-totalité donc une vague
compréhension des institutions
politiques
la quasi totalité des électeurs sont
politiquement ignorants ils n'ont même
pas liotta de l'ensemble des
informations pertinentes à la prise de
décision politique
ok il nous faut donc beaucoup mieux
informer les citoyens quoique ça c'est
vraiment pas facile mais supposons pour
aujourd'hui que par un coup de baguette
magique les citoyens soient tous aussi
informé que les hommes politiques les
plus informés la démocratie avec un
scrutin parfait des citoyens informés
serait-elle alors une garantie de
prendre toutes les meilleures décisions
possibles même là tu pas gagné dans ce
cas c'est pas gagné selon l'économiste
pointe caplanne selon brian caplanne
l'ignorance des citoyens n'est pas le
plus gros problème du vote démocratique
pour brahim caplanne le coeur du
problème c'est que les citoyens informés
ou non vote de manière irrationnelle
comme on l'a vu dans l'épisode précédent
la psychologie empiriques montrent que
les citoyens se comportent davantage
comme des hooligans que comme des
scientifiques bien souvent une intuition
émergents eux parfois en quelques
millisecondes seulement parce que tel ou
tel mot a été utilisé ou à cause des
traits physiques de l'interlocuteur est
dès lors toute nouvelle information sera
interprétée de sorte à justifier cette
intuition et les biens cognitif associé
à cette auto persuasion sont nombreux
les citoyens sont victimes du biais de
confirmation qui les pousse à chercher
plus longuement de l'information qui
conforte leur intuition
les citoyens sont victimes de la
dissonance cognitive qui les pousse à
rejeter souvent inconsciemment ce qui
contredit leur intuition
les citoyens sont victimes du
raisonnement motivés qui consiste à
fixer l'objectif du raisonnement
avant de commencer à raisonner les
citoyens sont victimes du billet de
disponibilité qui les pousse à centrer
leur raisonnement sur les exemples qui
l'ont en tête exemple souvent générées
par et pour leur intuition
les citoyens sont victimes du
communautarisme idéologique qui les
pousse à préférer échanger avec ceux
dont ils partagent déjà les idées les
citoyens sont victimes de la pression
des pairs qui les pousse à suivre l'avis
de ceux dont ils sont les plus proches
mais surtout les citoyens informés sont
beaucoup trop sûrs d'eux mêmes
à l'instar des étudiants de derek miller
ils ne comprennent pas qu'ils ne
comprennent pas le monde de la politique
malgré leur manque de familiarité avec
des notions basiques mais ô combien
contre intuitive de statistiques de sens
cognitive vue d'économies les citoyens
restent persuadés que leur camp et le
bon camp et que leur choix de caen est
une décision parfaitement justifiable et
justifiée or comme le dirait le
mathématicien john von neumann
si les gens ne croient pas que les
mathématiques sous simple c'est parce
qu'ils ne se rendent pas compte
d'à quel point la vie est compliquée or
cette irrationalité c'est pire que ligne
ans parce que vous pourrez peut-être
soigner l'ignorance par de l'information
mais soigné l'irrationalité demande
beaucoup beaucoup plus de travail mais
d'où vient cette irrationalité des
citoyens au moment du vote
après tout brenneca planète un
économiste et en tant qu'économiste il
trouve ça parfaitement raisonnable de
modéliser les êtres humains comme des
êtres rationnels en tout cas dans le
contexte de l'économie
mais pour brian caplanne le vote
démocratique n'a rien à voir avec les
décisions que l'on prend en économie en
effet en économie le choix d'un mauvais
produit d'un mauvais client ou d'un
mauvais dirigeant peut avoir des
conséquences économiques immédiates sur
les acheteurs les vendeurs et les
producteurs on l'a vu dans le jeu de
l'économie ne reste que les acteurs qui
ont su bien jouer le jeu cependant le
cas de la démocratie est l'exact opposé
les citoyens qui ont mal voté ne sortent
pas du jeu ils restent en jeu pire
encore si ces citoyens ont voté pour un
candidat qui n'a pas été élu alors le
candidat en question ne pourra pas les
avoir déçus et ses citoyens ne verront
aucune raison de remettre en cause leur
vote
mais qu'en est il des électeurs qui ont
voté pour un candidat qui a été élu et
qui a déçu n'observe alors empiriquement
que bien souvent si certains de ces
électeurs change alors leur vote
beaucoup persiste à voter pour le parti
du candidat en question les vrais
électeurs de droite continue à voter à
droite et les vrais électeurs de gauche
continuent à voter à gauche et ça ça
parait vachement irrationnel mais pour
braine caplanne il ya une explication
très simple à cela
si chaque citoyen qui a voté pour un
candidat qui a déçu peut regretter son
vote
aucun électeur ne se sent vraiment
responsable de l'élection du candidat
après tout chacun de nos votes n'a
virtuellement aucun effet la probabilité
qu'un vote soit décisif est comparable à
la probabilité de gagner au loto
elle est d'environ 1 sur le nombre
d'électeurs soit en france un sur
quelques millions et je parierais même
que si jamais il y avait une élection
qui se joue à quelques centaines de voix
seulement il y aurait alors tellement
d'incertitudes quant au résultat final
que le résultat de l'élection sera sans
doute annulé bref pour caplanne il y a
une énorme différence entre un vote et
un âge
lorsqu'on achète un produit la qualité
et le prix du produit vont nous affecter
directement il y a un gros incentive à
être rationnel lorsque l'on vote ce
qu'on achète surtout c'est le sentiment
du devoir citoyen accompli ainsi que ce
plaisir à avoir éternué nos convictions
de même manière que les patriotes
prennent plaisir à célébrer les valeurs
des leurs ou que les supporters d'une
équipe de foot prennent plaisir à
chanter en choeur un vote uniquement
guidés par le légalisme politique
s'accompagne de jouissance psychologique
alors qu'un votre raisonnée requiert
d'énormes efforts intellectuels pour
démêler le vrai du faux et anticiper les
conséquences sociétales et s'accompagne
d'une probabilité quasi nul d'avoir un
effet quelconque dès lors pour caplanne
les citoyens ont tout intérêt à voter
selon leur intuition et conformément à
lugano politique qui sommeille en eux et
il serait irrationnel pour eux de
dépenser du temps et de l'énergie pour
voter de manière informée et rationnelle
selon caplanne les citoyens sont non
seulement irrationnel dans leur vote ils
sont même rationnellement irrationnelle
la d re fois on a parlé de ligue à nice
mme politique et simon lepinat nous
renvoie vers un article qui a récemment
publié sur le site de ramon qui envoie
une publication scientifique en
psychologie qui montrent que les
individus se comporte de façon morale
non pas à cause des incentive et donc
cette remarque qu'elle remet carrément
en cause le fait d'appliquer la théorie
des jeux à tout le champ a priori en
fait pas tant que ça parce que dans les
modèles la théorie des jeux en fait
chacun fait ce qui est bien pour lui et
selon lui et dans le selon lui on peut
inclure des jugements moraux et
notamment le fait que les gens par
exemple considère qu'il est mal de voler
et qui serait mal pour selon eux qu'ils
soient en train de voler ça ça peut être
complètement inclus dans un modèle de
théorie des jeux et d'ailleurs à ce
sujet des coûts psychologique à faire
des choses qui sont mal je vous
conseille vraiment encore le livre de
jonathan ait il parle très bien des
jugements moraux que l'on attribue à
diverses choses et qui fournit aussi une
explication évolutive à tout cela et
d'ailleurs on y reviendra parce que tant
d'entre eux mêmes partie de ce livre il
lit tout ça notamment la théorie des
jeux évolutionnaire et la théorie de la
coopération
on y reviendra plus tard dans cette
série sur la démocratie le chevalier
pingouins nous demande aussi suivre nos
intuitions sait vraiment si mal que ça
il y affirme m je cite que la seule
bonne manière de penser c'est de penser
comme on le souhaite pas tellement
d'accord avec cela ça dépend ce que ça
veut dire penser je pense qu'il faut
séparer deux choses les opinions et ce
qu'on pense que le monde est trop m'en
dit à mon sens il faut séparer ce qu'on
appelle la pensée descriptif des cli le
monde tel qu'il est et la pensée
normative ou prescriptive qui essaie de
décrire comment le monde devrait être
une chance que ces deux domaines très
différents et en effet lorsqu'on essaie
de se penser ce que l'on devrait être a
priori c'est pas facile
voyez pas y'a pas une façon de dire ce
que le monde devrait être et avoir des
avis très différent
et d'ailleurs c'est toute la
problématique de la théorie des jeux
c'est tellement de la théorie des
scrutins s'étant donné des préférences
différentes des gens c'est à dire
dépenser normative différente chez les
différents individus d'un peuple au
moment où est-ce qu'on peut combiner ses
préférences normative de différents
individus pour prendre des décisions qui
s'appliquent à tout le monde
et j'insiste un petit peu sur ça la
vraie difficulté de la politique en
général par politique j'entends pas le
monde politique elle qui aujourd'hui la
manière d'organiser société pour que
différents individus vivent ensemble la
grosse difficulté qui vient avec la
fédération de différentes personnes avec
différentes pensée normative c'est que
ce que veut peut être complètement
incompatible avec ce que l'autre veut et
du coup il va falloir faire des
concessions si on veut continuer à vivre
en société et je me permets que même de
dire que le concept de société en
général en l'histoire de l'humanité nous
a permis
de vachement améliorer notre qualité de
vie c'est chacun d'entre nous vivent et
où ce serait compliqué pour toutes nous
tous aidé alors si on essaie de vivre
ensemble à il faut au moins essayer de
s'accorder sur un certaine pensée
commune ci en particulier est capable de
trouver des pensées normative commune à
toute une société passât peut quand même
aidé pas mal à fédérer les gens et à
organiser la société pour nous permettre
de vivre ensemble et de mieux vivre
ensemble inverse la pensée descriptive
c'est d'écrire tels que le monde et à
priori ça c'est quelque chose qui est
beaucoup moins subjectif et il ya des
manières de penser le monde qui sont non
seulement fausse mais qui sont même pas
du tout pertinente et qui sont qui
risque d'être très détriment talent au
futur de la personne qui pense ce genre
de choses encore une fois tous les
modèles sont faux certains sont utiles
ça serait bien quand même de connaître
ceux qui sont utiles à l'intérieur me
demande si le ligue à nice met une
fatalité
selon moi donc pas du tout je peux très
bien changer d'avis mais il faut du
temps il faut du temps et je pense
surtout qu'il est très très très très
utile en tout cas il m'a été très utile
d'être conscient de mon hooliganisme
politique parce que louis liga niveau
politique me renfermer toujours sur les
mêmes sujets et toujours la même façon
de penser le monde et à sortir de cet
organisme politique donc ça peut se
faire avec le temps et en fréquentant
des personnes qui ont un point de vue
très différents du nôtre mais je pense
que le plus simple le plus rapide le
mieux c'est encore d'être conscient de
son organisme politique mais aussi des
hooliganisme politiques des autres
personnes qui on parle pour voir comment
quelle est la meilleure façon de leur
parler d'adapter le message à chaque
fois la personne à qui vous parle je
pense que c'est très très très important
une même phrase peut très bien passé
dans un point certains auditoire est
très très très mal passé avoir un effet
d'être immortel pour un autre dit ouah
donc nous propose dans les vidéos
précédentes s'étaient pas de dire 'voilà
et tous les week-ends politique sa fin
du monde
tous enfermés dans nos convictions c'est
fini mon but dans la vidéo précédente
c'était surtout pour aider les gens à
prendre conscience de leur organisme
politique pour pouvoir amener de
meilleur débat et à mener une façon de
réfléchir qu'ils ne soient pas coller à
l'intuition et qui permet un peu sortir
un petit peu de notre mode de pensée
d'hooligans politique ce qui me permet
de rebondir sur la question de quentin
monarchy demande s'il ya un moyen de
réfléchir en oubliant son intuition et
ben je pense que le plus important c'est
un truc que j'ai c'est le moment de
mettre en avant sur sur toutes mes
vidéos 7 sur rolle c'est à mon sens
qu'il faut apprécier tout ce qui est
contre 1 qu'il faut apprécier le fait du
convaincre notre intuition que nos
traditions à tort et c'est un actif qui
est souvent très récurrent chez les
scientifiques ont même avoir tort on
aime quand l'expérience montre que la
théorie est fausse
parce qu'à ce moment là on peut se
remettre en question on peut avancer
parce que c'est en développant notre
intuition bien souvent que l'on fait les
plus grands au crès
ouais je pense que la meilleure façon de
penser sans son intuition c'est essayer
de montrer que notre intuition à tort et
de prendre plaisir à montrer que notre
intuition
à tort jarry à lui retourne nous
demandent comment du coup influencer
d'autres personnes si les autres
personnes se renferme dans l'or
hooliganisme politique
comment est-ce qu'on peut quand même les
convaincre et hier en pratique on arrive
quand même avec le temps à convaincre
les uns et les autres
bien souvent en tout cas selon jonathan
wright ce qui va permettre de convaincre
quelqu'un de telle ou telle position
c'est en jouant plus sur les émotions et
en jouant plus en fait avec lou ligan
politique de l'autre personne plutôt que
avec la raison des bas d'avocats fait
les avocats communiquent très très mal
de serre venir me koubbi avocat je pense
à la raison et c'est de mettre en avant
les arguments rationnels ce qui va plus
influencer les gens c'est plus au niveau
émotionnel au niveau de l'organe
politique si on peut essayer de
convaincre le yen poétique en l'autre
que telle position est séduisante
intéressante aussi c'est quelque chose
qui marche sera beaucoup mieux en
général que d'y aller avec la raison et
c'est pourquoi bien souvent on va
davantage préféré suivre les opinions
des gens que l'on admire déjà plutôt que
des gens qu'on ne connaît pas avoir des
gens que l'on n'aime pas quand à moi sur
scène soit si vous y réfléchissez toute
la série de vidéos et on va aller assez
loin dans cette série de vidéos vous
mettre des idées qui serait très très
très mal passé si j'avais eu directement
une vidéo là dessus et peut-être à la
fin de la série voilà peut-être que vous
n'avez pas trouvé ça scandaleux ce que
je vais dire que je trouverais ça on
verra mais en tout cas ma stratégie moi
ça a été d'essayer déjà de vous parler
de choses qui n'ont pas vraiment à voir
avec ce dont j'ai vraiment envie de
parler dans cette série de six de vous
séduire un peu avec des jolies
mathématiques une analyse sociologique
psychologique de la manière dont les
gens votent plein de résultats établis
puis j'ai essayé surtout de remettre en
cause vos intuitions essayer de penser
les choses différemment
toujours en essayant d'être séduisant
dans la manière dont on remet en cause
les intuitions des uns et des autres et
de même parce que je pense que le gros
problème c'est que souvent les gens sont
très très sueur des opinions qu'ils ont
et du coup tant qu'ils n'ont pas été
remises en cause ce à rien d'essayer de
mettre côté opinion dedans et j'espère
qu'une fois qu'on aura remis en cause
pas mal de choses on pourra commencer à
reconstruire et à essayer de mettre des
idées qui me semble plus intéressante
que les débats classique politique
alexis du 92 500 nous demande du coup si
ça sert à rien les débats politiques si
ça peut servir et débat politique à
condition que ça ne parte pas dans un
match de boxe entre union politique
malheureusement en pratique c'est très
souvent le cas et en pratique
trouve que ça fait pas avancer le débat
donc si on est entre amis et que chacun
se renferme dans ses gammes politique
basse à sa discussion sert à rien c'est
plutôt souvent même à énerver les uns et
les autres à agoniser jusqu à autre
chose
à moins que vous réussissiez à
structurer le débat pour éviter une
confrontation frontale entre une
politique du coup les bons débat
politique sans débat sont des débats où
l'élan s'oppose pas trop faut s'opposer
un petit peu tous dans le même sens il
ya la polarisation groupe via un trade à
face est difficile à atteindre mais un
trailer assez intéressant entre à quel
point on doit s'opposer et à quel point
on va s'accorder sur certains après les
débats politiques télévisés entre
politiciens ça au niveau de l'avancement
du débat je pense que ça sert pas à
grand chose en général je conseille
beaucoup plus utile d'aller voir des
vidéos youtube qui explique l économie
ou qui explique les qui donne des
chiffres de l'immigration je sais pas
trop quoi que d'écouter ce genre de
débat politique entre politiciens
l'objectif façon des politiciens lors
des débats politiques c'est pas de faire
avancer le débat
l'objectif de tout politicien c'est
d'être et de rester au pouvoir ce qui en
termes grassi correspond à gagner des
voix ouais je pense que pour avancer
dans le débat politique et pour voir
quelle est la meilleure façon de
structurer nos sociétés la meilleure
chose à faire c'est bas de s'intéresser
à la science politique à la philosophie
de meetic donc lire notamment des gens
comme jonathan ait brincat plane ou
aller voir des vidéos comme politique au
stupide economics ça ça vous fera
beaucoup mieux progresser dans le débat
politique
à mon sens que la plupart des débats
politiques classiques qui peut avoir
entre amis ou à la télé elle j'espère
que vous avez mais cet épisode cet
épisode clos un petit peu la partie un
petit peu plus sciences sociales sur la
démocratie on reviendra sur d'autres
concepts de sciences sociales plus tard
dans cette série mais
les élections sont passées je pense que
ça serait bien de faire d'arrêter un
petit peu la politique et de paris un
peu d'autres choses qui restent liés à
la politique à la démocratie mais qui
sera un petit peu plus fondamentalement
peu plus tôt ricard que je sais que
plusieurs parmi vous qui veulent que je
parle un peu plus de maths et du coup à
partir de la prochaine vidéo on va
rentrer un peu plus d'émotion de théorie
des jeux et sont un peu plus proche des
mathématiques en particulier dans la
prochaine vidéo ou parlera des axiomes
de vollmann morgenstern et de la
description classique les préférences
des individus en théorie des jeux et en
économie si vous avez aimez cette vidéo
pensez à liker a commenté à la partager
pensez à vous abonner pour autant qu
effectuera des visites
merci aux tipa repos leurs dons et
j'espère que vous serez là la prochaine
fois et 100 millisecondes c'est vraiment
rien du tout assez cette durée les 100
millisecondes vous avez même pas le
temps de bouger l'oeil pas le temps de
faire une saga de ça veut dire vous
n'avez même pas le temps d'observer le
visage quand vous présente malgré tout
si on vous demande de dire à quel point
une personne n'al'air agressive ou
extravertie ensemble ils vont vous être
capable de donner une réponse
et quand vous laisse 100 millisecondes
ou qu'on vous laisse deux heures votre
réponse sera la même ce qui montre qu'en
100 millisecondes
notre impression est déjà formé qu'elle
n'a plus bougé